>> Tucker: IT'S BEEN A COUPLE
DAYS NOW BUT LIBERALS ARE STILL
IN FULL HYSTERIA AND PANIC ON
THE IDEA THAT THEY MIGHT LOSE
THEIR MONOPOLY ON SPEECH IN THIS
COUNTRY SINCE ELON MUSK BOUGHT
TWITTER.
SHE THOUGHT A LOT ABOUT HOW TO
FIX TWITTER'S FREE SPEECH
PROBLEM, SHE'S A FREQUENT GUEST
HERE.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
SO IF YOU GET INTO THE DETAILS
IT'S ACTUALLY PRETTY
COMPLICATED.
HOW EXACTLY DO YOU FIX TWITTER'S
FREE-SPEECH PROBLEM?
>> FIRST, ELON MUSK HAS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT IF NOT THE
MOST IMPORTANT FREE-SPEECH
VEHICLES RIGHT NOW SO HE HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE THE
DISCOURSE IN THIS COUNTRY FOR
THE BETTER AND I THINK THERE'S A
FEW SIMPLE THINGS HE CAN DO.
FIRST OF ALL, MOVED TWITTER OUT
OF SAN FRANCISCO AND OUT OF
CALIFORNIA ALTOGETHER.
IF HE MOVES IT TO FLORIDA, I
THINK THAT WILL BE A HUGE
IMPROVEMENT IF HE MOVES IT OUT
OF CALIFORNIA.
I'VE SEEN A CALL TO FIRE
EMPLOYEES, I DON'T THINK HE
SHOULD DO THAT, I THINK THAT IS
EXTREME IT ALSO HAS LIABILITY
ISSUES.
BUT I THINK HE SHOULD APPLY FOR
DIFFERENT POSITIONS IN THE
COMPANY AND SEE IF THEY GO ALONG
WITH SOME NEW POLICIES I'M
TALKING ABOUT.
I THINK HE SHOULD LET BACK ONTO
TWITTER PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
BANNED AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE INCLUDING CLIENTS OF MY
FIRM, ROGAN O HANLEY IS
CURRENTLY SUING TWITTER AND WE
REPRESENT SOME MEME MEISTERS
LIKE MEGAN MURPHY, OF FEMINIST,
RADICAL CANADIAN PHARMACIST WHO
WAS KICKED OFF OF TWITTER FOR
SO-CALLED MIXED GENDER RING.
THE TRAFFIC ON TWITTER, WHICH IS
WHAT TWITTER SHOULD WANT TO
GOING BACK TO SOMETHING WE
LEARNED AS CHILDREN, TO BE
HONEST AND TRANSPARENT.
THAT HAS BEEN TREMENDOUSLY
LACKING IN TWITTER.
TWITTER HAS LIED ABOUT HOW IT IS
WITH THE FINGER ON THE SCALE
UNTIL AFTER THE FACT.
WHATEVER IS NOT TRANSPARENT
ABOUT ITS POLICIES, ITS
ALGORITHM, TWITTER IS NOT
TRANSPARENT ABOUT HOW PEOPLE ARE
REMOVED FROM THE PLATFORM AND
TWITTER IS NOT TRANSPARENT ABOUT
WHO ITS USERS ARE.
THEY TALKED ABOUT REMOVING THE
BOTS FROM TWITTER.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PUBLIC IT IF
HE IS, I'M SURE HE'S GETTING
INVITES FROM ALL OVER THE PLACE
AND OF COURSE I AM SUING TWITTER
SO THAT IS CERTAINLY A FACTOR IN
WHAT I HAVE TO SAY HERE, BUT HE
CAN DO ALL OF THESE THINGS I
SHOULD SAY IS CONTINUING TO
STRIKE THE BLOW TO FREE SPEECH
HE HAS BEEN DOING THE LAST FEW
DAYS.
I THINK THE GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
COMING FOR ELON MUSK FOR MONTHS.
THEY'VE BEEN COMING WITH THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT OF DISINFORMATION
PANEL THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
EXAMINE SO-CALLED DISINFORMATION
GOVERNANCE PANEL.
THAT IS THE GOVERNMENT TRYING TO
PROPOSED CENSORSHIP THAT
ELON MUSK SAYS IS NO LONGER TO
EXIST ON TWITTER.
I THINK WE ALL NEED TO STAND
TOGETHER FOR THAT AND HAVE OPEN
CONVERSATIONS.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO BEING
ON TWITTER FOR MANY YEARS
HOPEFULLY WITH THE FRESH
LEADERSHIP.
>> Tucker: THE PANEL YOU
TALKED ABOUT IS OUR LEAD FOR
TOMORROW'S SHOW.
ONE OF THE MOST BRAZEN ASSAULT
ON THE FIRST AMENDME